le lire au québec en laine ou le célèbre
et on l'achète 2015 aura été une bonne
année et beaucoup d'additions intéresse
en particulier
il ya eu certes un succès de librairie
des ventes prévue de plus de 600
millions de dollars juste au québec qui
enrichissent éditeurs distributeurs et
libraires mais pas toujours les auteurs
je n'ose même pas dire aux gens que je
suis payé en livre je trouve ça ridicule
elle c'est dévalorisant
c'est très grave d'autres vont jusqu'à
payer pour être publié j'en connais qui
ont acheté leurs livres comme les
centaines d'exemples à de leurs livres
c'était la seule condition pour que
l'éditeur les publie et tout le monde le
sait dans le milieu mais personne n'en
parle
tout le monde a peur de parler comment
expliquer qu'une industrie encadré par
la loi qui bénéficiait de subventions
tolère des pratiques douteuses au
détriment des créateurs
ma théorie à moi comme hauteur et star
ce qui écrire c'est l'utilisation que tu
fait de ton droit de parole que soient
payés peau tant mieux mais que soient
pas payés pour
keystone labrecque viennent souvent
fureter en librairie et elle qui ne rêve
qu'à écrire n'y trouve pas son premier
roman
il existe pourtant si 190 pages bien
solide
elle vit soudain à côté du château
madran gant noir et levé réel ses yeux
emplis de crainte
l'héroïne s'appelle sarah et puis elle a
15 ans lorsque j'avais quand j'ai
commencé l'écriture du roman
christine soumet son manuscrit à trois
éditeurs après le troisième reçues elles
répondent pas le je suis rendu au point
que je fais est dit et moi même donc
merci quand même de m'avoir posters et
alors c'est l'objet d'une réponse il a
dit dès ce vous êtes de prêts à en
acheter un certain nombre de copies et
j'espère que vous publiez christine
s'empresse d'annoncer la nouvelle sur
facebook elle a peut-être trouvé un
éditeur et poneys pour lequel marcel
broquet est connu dans le métier depuis
45 ans c'était mon choix
premier de me faire éditer par un
éditeur qui allait s'occuper de la
distribution et de toutes les paperasses
tout ce que je connais c'est pénible
monsieur broc et promet de prendre en
charge tous les coûts de production
prévision mise en page impression et
distribution mais pour publier le livre
je suis obligé dutil de vous demander d'
envisager un achat de 300 exemplaires le
demander un non état de participer à la
production commence à l'édition la
commercialisation du livre son
exploitation
ce pas une pratique dans les règles je
vous dirais tu acceptable
destiné pourtant avisé elle pose
beaucoup de questions à l'éditeur sur la
nature de son contrat et elle le
préviens je ne sais pas détecter le
danger écrit la jeune auteure car elle
est autiste
j'ai tendance à faire facilement
confiance peut-être un peu trop
peut-être que ça fait un peu partie de
mon syndrome d'asperger guerre qui est
une forme d'autisme donc on est décrit
comme un peu naïf socialement l'éditeur
insiste qu'elle doit lui faire confiance
j'ai ce n'est pas riche mais décide
d'engager toutes ses économies et signe
le contrat
au québec l'industrie du livre est régi
par la loi 51
elle prévoit le rôle de chacun des
maillons de la chaîne et la part qui lui
revient
le libraire père soit 40% du prix au
détail
le distributeur 20% l'auteur reçoit
généralement 10 % les derniers 30 % vont
à l'éditeur le risque de l'audace de
passe une année de sa vie ridge et à
écrire à créer des rames et centrer mais
denis d'italie du temps lui prend le
risque financier
si un grand nombre d'éditeurs ont une
pratique irréprochable notre enquête a
permis d'en identifier plusieurs et pas
des moindres qui font assumer le risque
financier aux autant est ce que ce sont
des hectares
chez nous ce sont des états reconnus
agri qui reçoit des sources also je peux
pas vous le confirme et j'en doute
à 94 ans la réputation de l'ornithologue
andré dion n'est plus à faire la
fondation qu'il a créée avec sa compagne
france dion à financer l'implantation de
centaines de nichoirs au québec
ensemble ils ont publié 25 ouvrages au
fil des ans l'odyssée du garrot
d'islande est une oeuvre de fiction
illustré on a déjà 3500 dans l'art de
dessins de payer on a déjà la correction
littéraire kenzo est presque 3000 $ ou
si le projet est déjà avancé lorsque les
dion le soumette à un éditeur à gré les
éditions gid à québec
au bout de trois semaines je reçois un
courriel de monsieur lambert qui veut
bien participer à la publication de
notes livre qui a trouvé ce beau qui a
montré sa son équipe mais qui aurait
besoin qu'on lui donne dix mille dollars
le projet implique trop de risques dit
l'éditeur et aucun profit en vue il
demande un minimum de dix mille dollars
avec ace mais ma décision est déjà prise
en échange il offre une quantité de
volume équivalent à la somme investie
mais il conserve tous les droits sur
l'oeuvre les droits lui appartenait g3
pour 6 heures on n'avait rien à tirer de
ce synode de sortir de l'aube ces
préceptes c'est ce qu'on a fait les dion
ont refusé mais d'autres ont accepté
l'auteur de ce livre qui ne veut pas
être identifié en a acheté 400
exemplaires pour 10000 dollars cette
entente de préachat ne fait pas partie
du contrat d'édition
je voudrais que ce une façon un but de
détourner les règles en effet qui est
contraire à la base le deuxième contrôle
aujourd'hui pour lui talât ma
connaissance
serge lambert le président des éditions
gid a consenti à nous parler au
téléphone c'est la pop long il dit qu'il
est loin d'être le seul à avoir recours
à cette pratique
moi j'ai énormément d'autres qui
viennent fille qui me racontent avec des
éditeurs pas n'importe laquelle
lamri personnes une à mal c'est aussi
une forme de contribution qu'on exige d
orwell carrément a pu bien failli pas de
livre true you rien les dion ont
finalement publié leurs livres eux-mêmes
et ont fait mentir les prévisions pour
nous c'était succès dans le sens que en
avant 1940 dans une année alors quelle
mesure nous disaient qu'ils seraient pas
bons qui qui voulaient 10000 dollars que
c'était risqué que c'était risqué
dès que christina break signe son
contrat l'éditeur marcel broquet seclin
d'avoir du mal à trouver un imprimeur à
très raisonnable le niveau comportait
trop de pages donc je vais devoir leur
maître à 49,95
c'est trop cher croit christine surtout
pour de jeunes lecteurs
le sucre qu'elle lui propose une option
que j'achète sans votre tombe donc 400
tombes au lieu de 300 donc on pour les
400 copies avec les taxes ça a donné un
total de onze 1745 et 29 euros
christine a investi près de 12000
dollars pour que son livre soit publiée
par une maison à gré rien de cela
n'apparaît au contrat et christine va
bientôt découvrir pourquoi
de l'eau sur le papier c'est une des
passions de francine allard est le titre
d'un de ses romans l'eau devenait
conductrice de forme et de lignes
étirées vers la lumière
ex présidente de l'association de
littérature jeunesse
essayiste romancier peintre francine
allard à publier 65 ouvrage mais c'est
l'écriture d'une lettre ou de voir qu'il
a entraînés au coeur de la controverse
avec les éditions trois pistoles
je ne voulais pas dénoncer la chaire
vitalie beaulieu dont j'aime beaucoup
les livres j'ai presque tous lui
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai voulu dénoncer
c'est exactement le fait qu'ils
donnaient pas de redevance leur
différend survient en 2012 après 5
années de fructueuse collaboration et
plusieurs succès de librairie la
confiance en ton éditeur tu aimes les
auteurs et puis tout à coup plus de
doigts et non seulement ça c'est pas
d'appel pas de retour d'appel
pas de courriel en face bilan étude de
rapports de vente
la loi oblige les éditeurs à produire un
bilan des ventes et des sommes dues et
l'auteur au minimum une fois l'an pas de
bilan
pas de chèque pour moi c'est important
même si j'avais des millions à la banque
ce que je travaille j'ai besoin d'être
rémunéré pour le travail que je fais ce
n'est pas seulement question d'argent
ont droit d'auteur c'était juste
curieuse de savoir combien de livres ont
été vendus
et voilà un exode asine a fui l'ex
yougoslavie
elle faisait face à des menaces de mort
pour avoir dénoncé le régime milosevic
son exil est devenue la trame de fond
d'un premier roman publié par victor
lévy beaulieu apprendre qu'un personnage
de la littérature québécoise a aimé mon
écriture et a décidé de me publier
et je prenais avec grande gratitude tout
ce que je recevais de victor lévy
beaulieu et j'ai reçu beaucoup j'ai reçu
un livre aucune critique aucune opinion
aucune présomption voir les autres
simplement comme des humains son
romantisme voit le jour en 2010 un an
plus tard et l'attend le relevé de les
dida et je n'ai jamais reçu mais encore
la petite immigrantes en moi a dit
battante et ça va venir
le bilan lui pervier deux ans après la
publication à nizas apprend que 237
exemplaires de son roman se sont vendus
et qu'elle aurait droit à 662 $
mais elle devra faire un choix et il m'a
dit vous pouvez choisir entre la chaîne
650 $ ou 350 livres que je vais vous
envoyer l'éditeur est en difficulté et
propose de payer ces redevances sous
forme de livre être payés ont été
propres livres
c'est conscient on rejette ce que tu as
donné et on dit autant cette poubelle
ton livre ça ça n'a pas de mal à ennezat
accepte à contrecoeur pour éviter que
l'éditeur ne s'en débarrasse
je ne pouvais pas prendre ça ça veut
dire j'ai jamais encaissé le chèque et
j'ai dans le sous sol de ma maison
305 rue moi il me devait tellement de
droits d'auteur que je leur ait fallu
que je me fasse bâtir une cabane est
particulière pour mettre les livres
qu'ils meurent est envoyée quand tu
travailles chez grave par exemple si tu
te fais pas payer par du macaroni grave
parce que tu travailles pour upi qui ont
des problèmes financiers à cette heure
et vous qu'on vous paie oui j'ai déjà
été payant livre c'est une pratique plus
courants de confiance un bond dans les
petites maisons en tout cas
du bas saint laurent où il a fondé sa
maison il ya 20 ans victor lévy beaulieu
mène de front ses deux métiers
d'écrivains et d'éditeurs
il défend la pratique de payer les
auteurs en livre ce qu'on appelle une
forme de troc
bon rien dans la loi interdit comme
auteur comme éditeur bugs troc avec
toyota
l'éditeur évoque un changement de
distributeur comme cause de ces
problèmes il a dû réduire son inventaire
et déménager les stocks chez lui ce qui
explique le retard dans le paiement de
ces redevances sur les cendres de sopore
à peu près qu'on a pu mais aux éditions
il ya encore deux ou trois qui ont été
oubliés mais selon le conseil des arts
il y a plus que deux ou trois auteurs en
cow boys
la liste des grands et l'organisme ne
considère pas le troc comme une forme de
paiements acceptables
un conseil des arts du canada
soutiennent les maisons d'édition pour
le soutien que ces maisons apporte aux
auteurs tant qu'à partir du moment où le
soutien n'est pas dans le standard quand
on demande en a le droit d'arrêter la
suivante les éditions trois pistoles ont
reçu plus d'un million aux fonds publics
depuis 20 ans le conseil des arts et la
sodec la société de développement des
entreprises culturelles ont retardé une
partie des subventions à l'éditeur l'an
dernier victor lévy beaulieu ne cache
pas son agacement devant la fronde des
hôtels qui m'insultent russie cei des
fouilles ça leur évite de de payant
puisque yahoo en a deux un temps mieux
tridge donc j'ai été rentable pour
réseaux et victor lévy beaulieu dit
traiter ses auteurs comme lui même l'a
été moi j'ai publié douze ouvrages à peu
près au canada anglais et à ce jour je
n'ai jamais reçu saute d'un need star de
droit d'ottawa
elles sont exemptes sont subventionnés
aussi par le conseil des arbres par
patrimoine canadien
pendant des années ils n'auraient pas
reçu non plus des rapports de vente pour
des ouvrages publiés ici chez quebecor
vous en ai pas fait un drame fait pour
vous la fais c'est de pouvoir être nu
l'algérie table bay c'est ça oui c'est
une réussite d'être publié c'est pas la
peine ça va à l'encontre de la loi des
droits d'auteur une mission petit cube
abouya degrés des rues de montréal ou
filet des autobus bondé de passagers
mouillé et mal réveillé dans le monde
littéraire où le salaire annuel moyen
n'atteint mène par trois mille dollars
yves beauchemin est une rareté il fait
partie de la poignée d'écrivains
québécois qui vit de sa plume
il faut se ralentir dans la tête que
c'est un métier c'est normal de vivre de
son travail même quand on est un
écrivain son matou a été vendu à plus
d'un million et demi d'exemplaires et
traduit en 16 ou 17 langues
sauf que le succès n'est pas synonyme de
fortune l'auteur obtient une modeste
avance lorsqu'il publie en langue
étrangère mais c'est tout en dehors du
canada et des états unis
il ne reçoit presque jamais de
redevances même lorsque ces prévues au
contrat
si j'avais eu à vivre uniquement avec
les droits étrangers
je pense que je suis a su bien être
social depuis l'autre pourtant vous avez
vendu des dizaines de milliers de livres
j'imagine moi je pourrais aller au
brésil pour vérifier sa plume il ya je
ne sais pas ses mystères un mystère
aussi pour ginette bureau
elle a appris avec étonnement que
quebecor avait vendu ses livres en
pologne on m'appelle pour me dire qu on
a besoin de votre pourquoi bon parce que
votive a été publiquement les voiliers
publié alors toute contente pour vous me
l'avez pas dit mon nom c'est l'histoire
de sa famille et du combat de sa fille
emportée par le cancer
désormais pour l'amour de ce que j'aime
je croirais à l'incroyable je crois à
ribemont enfant va vivre
le livre a connu un grand succès ici
dans les années 80 et a été transposée
au cinéma
quebecor en a obtenu les droits dans les
années 2000 je regardais sur internet
puis je voyais des salaires médecine
fait qu un lommois j'appelais faisait
comment se fait cap au dessous l'auteur
insiste pour connaître le montant des
ventes de la portable des web où on va
vous les envoyez vos deux chèques comme
un sommet de chefs avec parce que vous
avez publié mon appel je t'aime l'aide
vous avez publié les deux puis vous me
l'avez pas dire je t'aime la vie son
deuxième roman est aussi un best-seller
en pologne
ginette bureau obtiendra finalement
environ 4000 dollars de redevances il
faudra cinq ans avant qu'un agent en
europe lui révèle enfin combien de
livres l'avant du msb tout vendu plus de
trains mais j'étais un peu déçu parce
j'ai compris pourquoi qu'on y disposent
les chiffres parce que le chéquier pour
un rapport de la maison quand on me l'a
dit à chaque lot même si je divise en 2
j'aurais eu un bon 15000 quebecor dit ne
pas en avoir reçu davantage les auteurs
peuvent exiger de l'éditeur qui leur
ouvre ses livres mais peu osent où les
moyens de le faire quand on est une star
te dis j'ai tiré ton lit vingt cinq
mille exemplaires
tu dois le croire la parole donnée c'est
bien beau lomé
quelque chose là dedans qui repose sur
une naïveté obligatoire de quelques
heures
merci de broc est dans paysage
littéraire québécois depuis près de 50
ans comme libraire distributeurs et
éditeurs
en 2008 il fonde marcel broquet nouvelle
édition une demi douzaine d'auteurs
qu'il a publiés nous ont confié avoir dû
acheter leurs propres livres ou avoir
subi des pressions pour le faire non ça
c'est complètement faux je n'ai jamais
demandé un show un auteur contre rien
quand je publie un lille je dis bien aux
auteurs écoutez moi je suis pas une
entreprise philanthropique
je suis une entreprise commerciale votre
livre au grand public mais non pour me
faire ça c'est quelque chose que
l'éditeur met aujourd'hui pour faire nos
frais il faut vendre mes livres que ce
labrecque a accepté d'acheter les 400
premiers exemplaires de son roman sarah
fille de dragon elle s'attend donc
est-ce qu'il y en ait six cents autres
en librairie
la librairie aux il n'a pas reçu de
copie et ils m'ont dit qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas le commander parce que le
livre était plus disponible non plus
donc à ce moment-là j'ai demandé un peu
à mon éditeur mais j'ai pas eu de
réponse claire c'est seulement un an
plus tard en recevant son bilan que
christine obtient la réponse
le tirage est d'environ 500 exemplaires
c'est elle qui en a acheté la plus
grande partie ce qui représente
finalement presque 80% des tirages ben
c'est comme si tu prendrais tout d'abord
le chiffre 7 80% est impossible si on
soustrait du tirage les envois de presse
les ouvrages défectueux et les achats de
l'auteur il n'en reste que 133 pour le
grand réseau des libraires écoutez lieu
sérieux problèmes parce que vous avez
beaucoup et très très large sous avait
espoir de rejoindre marchés spots et
rapidement les seuls livres encore
disponibles sont ceux que christina chez
elles lui ont manqué mais mouvement
reste encore une bonne quantité est donc
à ce moment-là il a proposé de me
racheter
mais à une fraction du prix qui lui a
vendu on parlait à ce moment-là de 12 $
de livres mais ces livres là je les
avais acheté à 28 dollars
l'avez vous vu les chiffres oui
j'aimerais bien les voir moi-même c'est
pas ça veut pas je peux pas lui avoir
demandé deux fois le budget d'un but en
fin de partie assez pour donner s'ils
voulaient vraiment régler cette question
là c'est sortir les chiffres je suis
artiste vous avez confondu sortir le jus
que mon compte en banque
après l'entrevue monsieur broquet a
refusé de nous les fournir
mais le montant de 12 dollar apparaît
dans ce courrier la christine elle a
refusé de vendre son livre arabe et
c'est le far west
puis on exploite la rave de l'auteur
dans le sens où l'auteur est on exploite
sa naïveté face à son rêve
serge andré guay est un marginal dans le
monde du livre
il a fondé un service d'autoédition en
ligne sans but lucratif
certains des auteurs qui frappent à sa
porte fui l'édition traditionnelle
précisément parce qu'on leur a demandé
d'acheter de grandes quantités de leur
propre ouvrage
combien de gens ont accepté d'acheter
les mille premiers exemplaires sont
encore pris avec ça pour quoi faire
mais beaucoup d'auteurs qui accepte de
le faire moi j'en ai connu une dizaine
et des auteurs connus est trop souvent
une fois publié le livre ne vit pas
longtemps au bout de trois mois après
avoir célébré puis des photos de son
livre dans la vitrine du libraire
préféré en ce qu'on reçoit un appel de
l'éditeur qui me dit aline et retirer
les librairies si on veut acheter
d'exemple au québec on publie de plus en
plus 6000 nouveaux titres québécois ont
paru l'an dernier
mais le paradoxe c'est qu'on achète de
moins en moins des milliers de livres
sont pilonnés chaque année parce que les
ventes ne sont pas à la hauteur des
attentes
ça c'est un cauchemar alors que lui
parce connaître le succès frantz duval
ya cru elle a consacré 8 à produire le
livre de référence sur l'internet un
éditeur intéressé lui offre une avance
de trois mille dollars
mais le livre à peine publiés il lui
demande d'en acheter en échange de ces
modestes droits d'auteur et moi je lui
ai répondu pauvre monsieur comment vous
voulez j'achète et exemplaire qui reste
g.hn scène gg voir sous l'eau au bout
d'un an
l'éditeur revient à la charge avec de
mauvaises nouvelles
malheureusement votre livre ne sais pas
s'ils vont au dessus nous allons être
obligés de le solder
et de le pylône et madame duval lui
reproche d'avoir fait peu de promotion
pas même une mention lorsque son livre
est sélectionné en vue du prestigieux
prix roberval en france
en revanche il lui facturent les livres
envoyés au jury et les envois de presse
je les ai payées il m'a même fait payer
pur aux lettres puis elle découvre que
son livre est en vente partout dans le
monde
en version numérique dans le contrôle
c'est écrit noir sur blanc que tous les
droits du livre numérique
m'appartiennent alors ils n'avaient pas
le droit de la femme
l'éditeur et marcel broquet frange du
vol du lait vous que je fasse une crise
cardiaque
il a gardé un souvenir précis de son
auteur mais pas de la version numérique
de son livre on le dit trop content pour
me souvenir de ceux menacés de
poursuites monsieur briquet a rétrocédé
ses droits à l'auteur dans l'industrie
de la ville de l'excellence entreprendre
à découvrir
mais il ya aussi des entrepreneurs qui
sont devenus des simples fonctionnaires
du livre et dans ce sens là il ne gère
pas un business peu les jardins
subventions québec a donné 6 millions de
dollars en aide à l'édition en 2015
sans compter les 6 millions additionnels
accorder un crédit d'impôt en plus de
l'aide considérable du fédéral beaucoup
d'argent dit serge andré guay elle pas
en train de dire qu'on subventionne trop
non on se mange chaud
sans avoir les exigences à la hauteur
des subventions qu'on accorde pour être
éligibles les éditeurs doivent payer
leurs auteurs dans le cas des éditions
trois pistoles
victor lévy beaulieu a vu ses
subventions rétablie dès qu'il a corrigé
le problème
la seconde exigence et d'assumer seul le
risque financier de l'édition est-ce que
vous aviser les subventionnaires dans le
montage financier qui a une part du
financement qui vient des auteurs schilb
a soumis à la sodec le livre pour lequel
l'auteur a contribué en achetant 400
exemplaires pas juste une fois mais deux
années de suite
pendant ces deux années il a reçu
environ 60 milles dollars de subventions
ged a aussi présenté le titre au conseil
des arts du canada et il a été inclus
dans le calcul de sa subvention en 2011
ni la sodec lille conseil des arts
n'était au courant de la contribution de
l'auteur
quant au livre de christina break j'ai
support ne s'est pas vérifié je suis pas
nous avons vérifié mercèdre hockey a bel
et bien soumis le titre d christina la
sodec
il a obtenu presque 23 mille dollars de
subventions cette année là ce montant
n'inclut pas les somme généreuse
accordée aux éditeurs par le fonds du
livre du canada
marcel broquet aurait donc reçu une aide
financière en plus des 12 milles dollars
fournis par christine pour produire
sarah fille de dragon pour avoir une
idée des coûts nous l'avons soumis à
deux imprimeurs les deux exigent moins
de 4000 $ pour l'impression
tia de ce que j'ai payé ça comme
l'impression puis je crois que c'est
quand même une partie très très
dispendieux juste qu'à ce moment ça
voudrait dire que j'ai financé le livre
au complet plus en extraire les
pressions ne représente qu'une partie
des coûts mais christine n'est pas loin
de la vérité
normand tamaro avocat spécialisé en
droit d'auteur a examiné ses documents
premier constat à 28 dollars chacun
l'éditeur a vendu les livres 1 christine
trop cher si plus payant pour lui de
vendre à l'auteur que penser par une
structure beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs
parce que il reçoit 40 % du prix d'un
script à et ici reçoit 70 % de laudun en
s'appuyant sur les chiffres de l'éditeur
il fait ce deuxième constat dans ce
contexte là en me fiant aux usages de
l'ormeau quant au prix que reçoit ni
titre d'instructeur je m'aperçois que
c'est la dame qui finance
sur ces 400 copies vous me disiez que
500 copies d'imprimer ouais ça veut donc
dire que ce les 100 copies excédentaires
sont gratuites pour lui du couturier en
plus de renoncer à ces redevances
christine a fourni gratuitement
l'illustration de la couverture et à
payer 900 $ additionnels pour la
révision mais en fait j -p
promise en amont les rouges émises dans
ses poches c'est que c'est ce que tu dis
est revenu me voir ces questions je lui
ai dit vous avez posé les bonnes
questions
donc ce n'est pas une personne a ici une
personne qui s'est laissé convaincre par
une personne d'expérience
marcel braud qui refusent de porter
seuls le blanc sont tous les auditeurs
ils ont su mobiliser tous sans exception
lorsqu ils sont nombreux à faire
contribuer les auteurs ils vous le
diront comme dans vous diront pas mais
il ya des auteurs très connu ici qui
sont passés par là la sadique dit avoir
reçu une plainte d'un autre auteur
contre marcel broquet mais ne pas avoir
mené des enquêtes de son côté l'année
elle dit n'avoir aucun pouvoir de
coercition sur ses membres puisqu'elle
n'est pas un ordre professionnel
demain pour moins que nous dans au moins
d'assurance que si ses portes à notre
attention on refaire un recours auprès
d'éditeurs et on va dire
qu'effectivement ce pas une presse
secret command
christine a écrit une suite aux
aventures de son héroïne
mais comme le premier livre n'est plus
disponible étant que l'éditeur en
possède les droits
il sera difficile de la public
honnêtement ça m'avait un peu découragé
le 6 mai s'est pas complètement parce
que j'adore les patients et puis j'en ai
d'autres j'en ai doubt en tête
il ne lui manque qu'un éditeur en qui
elle pourra avoir confiance